the dream was never one about mastery or
being a lord
the dream the entire time was about
sustenance
about one brother joseph keeping the
others alive
in the famine grew grave in the land and
it happened when they had eaten up the
provisions that they had brought to
egypt that their father said to them
go back buy us some food and judah said
to him saying the man firmly warned us
saying you shall not see my face
unless your brother is with you and of
course in verse 11
israel relents he has to relent if it
must be so
do it and of course they
they go back they take double the silver
they bring benjamin to joseph
and they meet joseph one more time and
they explain to him how they got the
silver in the back and that they've
brought back even more
silver and joseph reassures
them all is well with you do not fear
your god and the god of your father
has placed treasure for you in your bags
your silver has come to me
and he brought simeon out to them and
the man brought the men into joseph's
house and he gave them water and they
bathed their feet
and they prepared a tribute against
joseph's arrival at noon
for they had heard that there would they
would eat bread and joseph came into the
house
and they brought him the tribute that
was in their hand into the house
and they bowed down to him at the ground
that beautiful bowing down moment again
the dream coming to pass
and he has asked how they were and he
said is it well with your aged father of
whom you spoke
is he still alive and they said all is
well with your servant our father
he is still alive and they bowed down
one more time
and he raised his eyes and here it is
and he saw benjamin his brother
his mother's son and he says is this
your youngest brother
of whom you spoke to me and they said
god be gracious to you my son and joseph
hurried out for his feelings for his
brother
overwhelmed him and he wanted to weep
and he went into the chamber and wept
there and he bathed his face and came
out and he held himself in check
and he said serve bread and this is a
stunning moment the
meal is such a brief scene but it's so
perfect
and they were seated before him the
first born according to his birthright
the youngest according to his youth and
the men
marveled to each other and of course
what they're marveling at here is that
joseph would actually know the birth
order
that he can put them in the correct
position and he had portions passed to
them from before and benjamin's portion
was five
times more than the portion of all the
rest as if
joseph is reminding them of the
favoritism
that is there with benjamin so yes
everything is right all the birth order
is in place
and yet we see favor
heaped upon benjamin here and this of
course
leads us to chapter 44 leads us to
joseph's ultimate plan to put the goblet
inside of benjamin's bag
to accuse him of stealing he says
how could we steal from your master's
house silver or gold
he of your servants with whom it be
found
shall die and what's more we shall
become slaves to our lord
and he said even so is by your words let
it be
he with whom it be found shall become a
slave to me
and you shall be clear and they hurried
and each man set down his bag on the
ground and each opened his bag and he
searched
beginning with the oldest and ending
with the youngest and he found the
goblet in benjamin's bag
note what joseph is going to do here he
says the man
in whose hand the goblet was found he
shall become my
slave and you you go and peace to your
father look at that line
you go in peace to your father they know
there will be no peace
here as they go to their father and this
really is kind of the stunning moment
this is joseph
playing off of the entire history of
what they have done to him
the entire history of the favoritism in
the family because think about what they
have
now their father's beloved son
benjamin what has he been accused of a
thief oh think about how delicious this
could be going back
to israel they could look at him and say
your beloved son
is a thief look at how wrong you were
to favor this thief but for some reason
judah can't
do so he gives to joseph the back story
he says and your servant our father said
to us you know that
two did my wife bear me and one went out
from me and i thought
oh he's been torn to shreds and i have
not seen him since
and should you take this one too from my
presence in harm befall him
you would bring down my gray head and
evil to shale
and so should i come to your servant my
father and the lad not be with
us this is so important for his life is
bound to the lads
when he saw that the lad was not with us
he would die
and your servants would bring down the
gray head of your servant
our father in sorrow to shale
and so let your servant pray stay
instead of the lad
as a slave to my lord and let the lad go
up with his brothers
for how shall i go up to my father if
the lad not be with us
judah in this beautiful end to this
penitential narrative
he who recommended that they sell
joseph into slavery takes slavery on
himself
and he takes slavery on himself on
behalf
of one that that he assumes is guilty
and he and he sacrifices himself
for really a stunning reason and that
reason is the love
of his father in many ways i see judah
as the hero of this story what would it
take think about the love that he has
for his father
[Music]
to fear that he would go down to shale
morning to be able to
swallow all of that rivalry
all of the enmity that he has for his
brother and all of the favoritism that
his father
has been heaping on joseph and benjamin
this entire time
and judah is willing to take all that on
and stay
in benjamin's stead on out of love
for his father and of course joseph sees
that the entire narrative has been
disrupted
that judah is broken free that the
joseph story is no longer that there is
something new here there is a
reconciliation
that the brothers have come around
in chapter 45 we get to see the reunion
and joseph could no longer hold himself
in check
before all who stood in attendance upon
him and he cried
clear out everyone around me and no man
stood with him when joseph made himself
known to his brothers
and he wept aloud and the egyptians
heard and the house of pharaoh heard
and joseph said to his brothers i am
joseph
is my father still alive but his
brothers could not answer him
for they were dismayed before him and
joseph said to his brothers
come close to me pray and they came
close and he said
i am joseph your brother whom you sold
into egypt
and so now do not be pained and do not
be incensed with yourselves that you
sold me down here because for sustenance
god has sent me
before you two years now there has been
famine in the heart of the land
and there are yet five years without
plowing at harvest and god has sent me
before you
to make you a remnant on earth and to
preserve your life
for you to be a great surviving group
and now to bring this the the story of
the sibling rivalry
full circle joseph finally reads his
dream
that the dream was never one about
mastery or being a lord
the dream the entire time was about
sustenance
about one brother joseph keeping the
others alive
he rejects their dream of lord and
master and rather offers them to this
understanding of this dream this dream
of sustenance
that joseph will in fact take care of
them
joseph the dream reader now finally gets
to read the dream
of joseph the dreamer the young man who
didn't understand the dreams he
understands
now thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all
of hillsdale college's online courses
they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn